[Musik]
hallo erst vollkommen zufällig weil
heute gibt einem leckeren eiersalat und
zwar besteht er auf hartgekochten eiern
und einer selbst gemachten mayonnaise
mayonnaise habe ich auf meinem kanalweg
ich mich selber gemacht und viele trauen
sich auch nicht dran weil sie dann längs
oder kann viel schiefgehen
aber ich zeige euch heute das eine
mayonnaise ganz einfach zuzubereiten ist
und wenn ihr die papis beachtet dann ist
auch wirklich gelingt sicher durch
glaube ich in einer salat gegessen kann
sein
für fußball und dem uran hat leider
männerschmuck deswegen dass er sich
jetzt die ganze zeit über hinlegen und
bisschen schlafen und ich koche und
backe heute.de salat bringe ich wieder
auf die beine
also ich sag jetzt mal die zutaten für
den einer seiner frau missachtet
gekochte eier der exkurs ich habe ich
noch mitläufer zwei esslöffel curry von
vorne halbe zitrone unterhalb davon
jeweils im saft einer zufolge sehr
frisch sein 100 milliliter ab deshalb
und treffer hier habe ich einen feigen
sind also eher süßlichen fruchtigen 56
gramm joghurt da habe ich etwas
stichfesten top ten joghurt ich hatte
zuerst mal die mayonnaise herstellen
könnt ihr das nicht machen wollt könnt
ihr auch eine fertige nehmen aber ich
finde ich sehr schade denn der frische
magnetischen natürlich bis er braucht
natürlich ein ganz frisches 1 damit
brauche ich die leute und der zitronen
ihr könnt aber auch beispiele vor
[Musik]
und findet erst einmal mit einem
schneebesen gut verrührt mit rapsöl eine
bremskraft immer nur in einem fall dass
google damit dieser sei mit den bösen
verfügen kann
[Musik]
die mayonnaise an dieser stelle einmal
abschmecken
gut wie perfekt ich gebe hier ist
allerdings noch ein bisschen joghurt
rein und zwar machte okotie mayonnaise
von bisschen leichter und bringt ja auch
noch mal die teure mit dann noch einen
teelöffel wenden kann nämlich den feigen
sind und vergibt denn bei unseren globus
david ihr bei uns um die ecke gemacht in
altlußheim kunden lieben ihn krebs die
macht den immer und verkauft den darm
und wer es wirklich super lecker hatte
verschiedene sorten und es ist mal was
aus der region
[Musik]
ich sah es jetzt kurz zur seite macht
ihr ein bisschen platz dann werden jetzt
die eier getreten und habe ich die
gekocht und dann als runter kaltem
wasser abgespült gibt zwei verschiedene
varianten einmal die papa variante und
war dann zwischen der hand rollen und
dann geht die schale super einfach weg
wenn man diese zwischen haut läuft dann
kann man das ganz einfach hier entfernen
[Musik]
timo rath variante richtigen krieg oben
und unten recht locker keck nv machen
aber er liegt krank im bett
ich glaube ich habe die kraft weg bevor
der markante muster morath macht für
mich mache die alte variante die eier
und die brauchen gruppen werden in
kleine würfel schneiden können jetzt
entweder mit messer machen oder zu
machen alle garten schneider
[Musik]
die ganzen vorgarten schon verbinden
ohne den rat gerne etwas flippiger haben
wollt dann könnt ihr einfach mit den
größer schneiden da kommt die schweiz
auch da wo dann carey ergibt einfach
kaffeepulver nach geschmack hat christin
auch auf der orangensaft und currypulver
und dann die leckere miami
[Musik]
könnt ihr an dieser stelle den salat
noch mal mit salz pfeffer und zum
beispiel auch ortschaft oder zitrone
abschmecken
obwohl ich lasse nicht den kühlschrank
abgedeckt noch etwa 1 stunde sehen
lieber morath ich habt ihr das jetzt
hier schon mal auf einem verbot gegeben
habe ich den selbst gemachten fenster in
den vertriebs- und so für ein kaltes
buffet für eine party als brotaufstrich
für den abend auch keine ahnung was vor
setzen können gummi aber wir alle hier
also ein kleines team wir haben probiert
und eiserner steg ist ein lecker vor
allem fand ich die magnete superlecker
also die werde ich auf jeden fall noch
mal machen vielleicht auch mal ohne
joghurt das ist auch eine tolle
alternative den duft schmeckt also ich
finde selbst gemacht schmeckt nicht so
schwer wie gekauft um ein männchen
florida fand doch mal zum abgehen
deshalb ermittle der tipp für den murat
das eine dann gut auf die beine kommt
halte dieses rezept nachmachen wolfgang
geht auffällig - doch der etat steht
nochmals und ich wünsche euch jetzt noch
mal ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und
bis zum nächsten mal auch als mensch
noch frisch
ich mach die alte variante oder einer
von euch muss mir einfach kein problem
ist voll verein punkten für einen
sportler mehr kommt den abschluss machen
fusion von zuschauern zeigen wie das
geht
die anderen dürfen in der schlosserei
und schüttauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]